[Musique]
et on commence par le choeur de la crue
la seine et marne on l'apercevait du
ciel le film de la journée à mort et aux
alentours clément le goff tri sur le
bras lorsque nous arrivons à
moret-sur-loing cet après midi c'est une
ville fantôme
personne dans les rues
seul occupe la route franchi les
portails et encerclent les maisons pas
un bruit
le musée le stade ont été désertés les
habitations aussi sauf une dans la rue
principale un irréductible est resté
l'eau est à sa porte
vous êtes le dernier de la rua pas avoir
été évacués
jeune homme j'ai refusé d'être évacuées
parce que j'avais j'avais pas eu le
temps de vider mais bibliothèques et des
tas d'objets les montées aux premiers
qui étaient des objets de valeur qui
aurait craint l'eau et je voulais pas
que in greece des transformers bouillie
par une vague ni pour vos protégés alors
j'ai mis des idées des sacs de sable des
planches et puis j'ai ben ouais tout
avec eux du tenue du bris du film
plastique pour eux étant chez g derrière
sa maison son jardin lui est déjà
inondés comme les autres et le niveau de
l'eau ne semble pas baisser
[Applaudissements]
la ville est traversée par la rivière et
regarder dans certains quartiers c'est
devenu un torrent pour nous impossible
d'aller plus loin dans la rue principale
quelques heures plus tôt ce matin dans
le village voisin de saint mamet c'est
un compte à rebours on se relaie pour
protéger les commerces avec des planches
et des parpaings
je suis bagdad depuis hier depuis 7h30
du matin et je suis pas rentrer à la
maison là j'ai pas encore dormi voilà
certains sauve l'électroménager d'autres
se mettent à l'abri
le cas est submergé il faut quitter les
maisons
vous aviez déjà été évacués comme ça
tous n'ont jamais combien 82 85 ans
passés pour boire ça devant la mairie
les secours s'organisent une personne
âgée doit être évacué en urgence parce
que je vais m'occuper sa pompe à
morphine ne fonctionne plus l'appui
d'électricité depuis hier soir 22h donc
on arrive enfin d'autonomie de deux des
appareillages est ce que le dragon peut
décoller je ne sais pas c'est finalement
un hélicoptère de la sécurité civile qui
viendra la délivrer de sa maison à
l'abri bien loin des inondations mais au
même moment certaines péniche menace de
basculer sur le bateau suspens au
travers de la vente au fonds de
poursuivre votre grade et il faut les à
marie celle ci sera attaché à un arbre
un peu plus loin une autre est posé sur
le quai
ce soir dans ces deux communes l'eau
n'est pas redescendue et peinent à
s'écouler sous les pins
[Musique]